mit m way jeden und alles was dazu
braucht punkt ch
sie stiegen flüge flüge mit der berufung
träumen
die auf der ifa 2 sie gehört
wurde vor sieben jahren ist familie
maggioni abruf dubai vertreten job als
pilotkunden acht jahre und selina hat
sich in der schule plötzlich auf
englisch müsse zurechtfinden dem motto
monika h das alles läuft
sonys neues glück gefunden
wolfgang jurgan finde ich da wird
familie passiert dass wir sie finden und
auch warum die beiden teenager schweiz
im internat leben als internationale
metropole
[Musik]
dubai der seite statt
der bauch rahmen als wahrzeichen vor 50
jahren bestieg sie mit der beduinen und
ihrer kammer mit 30 einwohnern handel
[Musik]
juni wieder retov dubai holding zum die
fluggesellschaft emirates schaffen
klassisches formation ist dass ich da
überhaupt empfangen werde ist für mich
nicht verständlich familie maggioni hat
turbulente zeiten hinter sich
auswanderer ist ganz anders als das sie
sich wünscht und krieg sind sie bereit
ihre geschichte erzählen
[Musik]
dies wäre immer so ruhig als pilot
fritsch metro auftrieb ist das sie
begleitet wahnsinnig dass ich das für
zig sehen diesen der spannende zeit
es ist viel passiert
und natürlich rooney macht sich 2008 als
erster auf nach
bei vier monate später folgten ihm die
achtjährige chiara und die zehnjährige
celina
und seine frau monika
[Musik]
vom bernischen niederbipp nach dubai ein
großer schritt in eine komplett andere
kultur
[Musik]
mit de-mail zu
strom
[Musik]
stark geschwächt
ricoh arbeitet als pilot seine familie
muss oft auf ihn verzichten denn er
fliegt blockweise immer zwischen drei
und sieben tage ist er weg
jara und selina besuchen eine englische
schule kein einfaches unterfangen den
alltag plötzlich in einer fremdsprache
zu bestreiten ihre mitschüler alles
kinder von menschen die ebenfalls wegen
der arbeit nach dubai gekommen sind so
genannten experts
[Musik]
andere kultur andere sitten das erfahren
die man schon spätestens als ihre möbel
angeliefert werden insbesondere bei
selinas klavier
wer nicht beharrlich bleibt wird
übergangen monikas hartnäckigkeit zahlt
sich aus das klavier findet dann doch
noch den weg nach oben
[Applaus]
[Musik]
selina kind nicht nur den passenden ort
für ihr klavier sondern auch für sich
selbst ihre aufgabe als mutter gibt
monika zuhause fußmassagen
gerne würde monika ihre massagen auch
professionell anbieten
doch sie erhält dafür keine
arbeitsbewilligung
in ihrer gemeinsamen freizeit erkunden
die man so ließ die umgebung auf den
kindern scheint das leben in dubai zu
gefallen
hier ist ganz klar dass ich spüre dass
ein
das schicksal familie lebte reto 12
[Musik]
familie situation nicht stimmen und
familie frank in oslo wird zu führen und
an stangen ist als wahrscheinlich
natürlich passiert es andere als familie
projekt macht nur wenn es für alle
stimmt aber was ist wenn nicht
vorstellen verändert bis maggioni satz
dazu geführt dass jetzt alle bis auf der
retro wieder in der schweiz leben
bachenbülach in der ivz
wie ist es wenn plötzlich zurück will
aber andere nötig für ihre familie und
auf ihre pcs
[Gelächter]
die ältere tochter große klima wirklich
einfach schweiz ist die zwei
verschiedene welten passiert als er
stieg merkt dass es bestimmt vettel de
red und monika sondern
sie herr 2013 zu quälen ihn schweiz wie
siehst du bei mini machen
das verstehe ich noch nie ganz vorbei
dass man möglichst sich solche extrem
skifahrer machen
ja ja im auto macht weiß nicht was nach
der schule oder mit vorne fahren
denn mama papa und einfache und denn ich
sage sie das sofort die frühlingsferien
heimische bekleckert es mit dem superhit
schweizer smi york machte sie noch nicht
ja und wie minarette schwitzig um ihnen
mit zug und daher einfach chris menz ist
obliegen angelina ist zurück die schweiz
ins internat am wochende hat sie bei
ihrer gewohnt hat sich aber auch monika
nie wohlgefühlt dubai und denic und
sauce ist ebenso laden ist für mich
super league sion in bollewick sitze
woche lang
95 bildet dann wieder zurück hobby nach
dubai und einfach das machen was macht
man das dubai in kriegen zu fangen aber
eigentlich wäre der perfekte zeitpunkt
zum beruflich gasquet nummer aus expert
frau ist es für monika nicht möglich sie
zu schaffen
wenigstens nicht legal unzufriedenheit
im mai auf beziehung von monika dem redo
abgeklärt verständnis für den anderen
ein stück für stück abgenommen
für die führung 15
das gespräch gesucht und will das aber
möchte in dubai bleiben und drehte 15
uhr oder pensioniert ist quasi bisschen
immer flüge bereits und da ist das ist
reiner und dem ruhrgebiet und unflexibel
nach einem und familien ist schon
wichtigste
rektor prof was ist das für ein moment
sie wollen ja dass bei die realisierten
das gesetz soll nach unumkehrbar ist
eigentlich schon mehrfach also das ist
immer wieder so viel hörst und tiefs
training xii ich frag mich die gruppe
carso media show am schluss vor der
beziehung mit zusammen 16 24 immer
wieder so ein angriffspunkt
auseinandersetzung kann einfach weil es
ja nicht für möglich
ich kann das machen wollen oder zu
verarbeitet oder kurz nach damit dass
sprachen mit monika das was mich
entschlossen schweiz druck da steht aber
mich ist trotzdem versuchen zurück und
beendet wurde
wahrscheinlich miss bemühe zum zum
bezirk niedersachsen hat dieser musik
zum möglich dass die sicherung
verletzungen
von der ziege droht also muss ich so
langsam axel kraus dieses haben und wenn
es nur mit seiner grund natürlich danken
urteil das die frauen hier bezirk ak mit
vorliebe wieder mit ihr zusammen das duo
am anfang einfach einfach wirklich noch
sehr lange zeit dass es das jetzt nicht
funktioniert dass die beziehung
funktioniert aber ja sicher immer noch
komisch für mich hat swiss re partnerin
romy zeit vergangen ist alles verschafft
werden verarbeitet werden und die
familien an der saline cdu angeführt in
brühl im kanton schwyz sie starke
symptome 30 sportrichtern an die jüngere
schwester chiara und macht die 72
jährige selina eine ausbildung zur
fachfrau betreuung jara deutsche weg
ziemlich schräg spitze vermisster
familie aber halt war am wochenende in
gutach und dort nach einer familie die
[Gelächter]
mitte märz nicht so schwarz
chiara abholen
kritik und übers wochenende internat ali
unbedingt als teenager unkompliziert zum
beispiel öffentlich
irgendwie aktuelles zwischen menowin
fröhlich und so einen hass entspricht
und das steht für immer unterstellen ich
das nicht so etwas gar nicht s&t maximal
augen regelnde von angriff verliert und
[Gelächter]
dubai hat die beiden schwestern sei mit
schweißt häufig sind ihre freundinnen
schon nach kurzer zeit wie dort sorge
sie beide sind sie ja bremer blieben die
15 jährige chiara hat grafik bestanden
und ihrem ärgsten ziel ist matura vom
beschaulichen ball zukunft dubai es ist
stadt vor der extrem
da ich alles höhe und größe und menge
los als an anderen ort trotz
temperaturen bis 50 grad da muss faire
spiel und steril
ich kann nachvollziehen dass monika
celina und jahre kennt in ein künstliche
kosmos wurzelstock
der rekord für sie ihren weg gefunden
und da gerade die beiden bretter dazu
erich im skiclub vom arbeitgeber emirats
skifahrer aus stück die heimat das hat
nichts mit die würste waren mindestens
einmal in der woche trainieren
[Musik]
wir sind früh übt sich noch nicht viel
los
zu staecks kurzer halt du bei jungen als
darum plane start zur zweiten skihalle
mit der längsten in der piste von der
welt 12 km
sie werden von der altpeter rund aus
kamerun und den überdimensionalen früher
turm luft geplant bande effekt also
damit beispiel spricht mit dem schwimmer
bord des super schönen ostsee und am 28
[Musik]
es ist sehr schnelllebig experten
natürlich auch von der bevölkerung in
dubai sie exportieren zu verschaffen zum
beruf gerne geblieben ist im studio
diebe verschafften sich um eine separate
größe werde ich habe die chance
für vermietete kollegin account danach
stetig wachse wiederum sehr schnell hat
sich schwierig zum möglich mögliche
gründe
[Musik]
mit ihrer neuen beziehung
alleine was wahrscheinlich schwierig
würde ich sagen also von schnell einsam
vielen dank
ja
zweimal mit seiner freundin baut sich
verrät uns dubai jetzt stück für stück
was neues leben auf aber nicht nur für
die heimische journal für alle ausländer
da sind über 80 prozent der bevölkerung
reto hat gelernt sich zu arrangieren mit
der strengen regeln
genauso wie sie noch quer über stress in
der familie mayerhöfer schaffe de facto
als pilot und es in fast zur gleichen
zeit wie man schon
sie sind schicksalsgenossen formation
ist aber sind offenbar ein weg gefunden
wie sie aus familien aus klein schauen
die entscheidung fällt und für mich ist
das okay natürlich gerne familie hätten
und ich bin hauptmeister heiß ich sag
ich jetzt mal für mich so schnell stimme
und das ist immer mein job und als pilot
doch was heißt dass man sich bezahlt als
expert familie versteckt zug ihre
chancen auf eine arbeitsbewilligung sind
viel spielraum
[Musik]
letzten mal sprachlos schütze dich
spitze ist die arabische kultur im
haushalt vom trend nationalhymne vor die
vereinigte arabische emirate sven dick
was sie singen nicht recht gemacht und
nach der geburt sondern als emotionale
unterstützung
die schweiz wird monika traffic endlich
nagel
sie schufen weg zum abschlussgespräch
mit der frisch gebackene mutter
[Musik]
als du laufen bringt monika viel zieht
mit ihren kundinnen menge 24 stunden am
stück als partei kinder genannt
und jetzt mittels novum in dieser woche
hat das gebot ist so einfach wie du
jetzt über eine geburt oh danke schön
für das foto oder video select geburt
wenn du lange aber spannen die uns und
sich ein schönes daraus das wunder in
dem moment wo geburt durch und ließ erst
mal einen ton von sich gibt
das ist unbeschreiblich mitbrachten
an ideen aufgeschrieben damit mit dem
monika nicht als in miami berichtete
erlaubt will ihn ja sie alles eine frage
egal was sie für das thema kochen egal
was für sie gewesen oder was für die
sich zum thema schwangerschaft oder
geburt kann sie alles reine farce für
mich sie ganzen eine vertrauensperson
wurde auf 1 7 huber vom eigenen
geschlecht noch ganz am anfang steht
monika das tool avisiere bis gefunden wo
sie erfüllt und ihre wie
geburtsvorbereitung machen aber die
haben sich nicht wie eine normale geburt
vorbereiten vorstellen
als ich lief andere themen wie zum
beispiel das mit affirmationen schaffe
so dass der gedanke sehr wichtig weil
der donau wo sie ihre energie ist das
einfach spüren
der weg ist neues leben
monika weiß wann sie für ihre
selbständigkeit sie träumt sogar schon
von meiner eigenen geburts bachenbülach
am wochende ist freie wege komplett
[Gelächter]
hofer ist immer das problem
[Musik]
sonys eingerichtet die neue lab trend
voneinander celina und chiara halten
kontakt zu dubai und zu ihrem vater
rupprecht
auch monika otto prinz immer gut
miteinander der weg als bei der city
fertig aber dass ältere gezielt
unterstützt dich du bist du ja
finanziell einfach sehr gut für oslo
entsorgen
also mir warte so gut unterstützt sie
finanziell dass ich glücklich aber genau
die freiheit haben sie mit muskel
schaffe es nicht dass ich an kein druck
ich habe jetzt mit dem aufbau von ihnen
geschafft wirklich die ca was hat
einfach braucht weil einfach weiß
finanziell ist abgesichert wenn du nicht
und jetzt so eine bestimmte monika und
ihre zwei töchter
als gutes team während madonnas hit
techno thema wenn du bei kukksi war ich
dort hat man vor ihnen
[Musik]
perus antritt muss lernen abschlüsse und
fürsorgepflicht und die erfahrung der
macho
verglichen mit 47 punkten dasteht punkt
ohne tank 1700 sie das jetzt das jetzt
tobi familie in der schweiz kritik
wieder andere
[Musik]
die zukunft
aber eigentlich zurückgeschnitten drehen
also du liebst mit den freundinnen nach
wie vor einigen monaten ob die schweiz
zum zum sind sie also das wird die achte
halte aber zum möglichen im moment ist
das jetzt noch nicht sagen
wie sie us wanderer sind träume in
erfüllung gegangen aber sie enthalten
zum schicksal in die eigenen hände und
suche gemacht nach dem leiter wofür sie
stimmt zu verschieden ihre geschichten
sind sind sich alle einig der schritt in
das neues leben als sieglos
[Musik]
zieler hier aus zog des msc kassel
mit m way jeden und alles was dazu
braucht punkt ch